okay so this is the Apple watch this is
Apple's first attempt at wearable tech
and this is everything you need to know
about it
first of all there are three versions of
the Apple watch Apple watch sport Apple
watch and Apple watch Edition and the
only difference between these three
versions is the materials that they're
made of and the bands also every watch
comes in two sizes a 38 millimeter and
the 42 millimeter not that much of a
difference in number but most likely a
men's size and a woman's size but do
note that the 38 is extremely small and
a lot of women will actually go with the
42 anyway the Moto 360 for example by
comparison is a 46 millimeter diameter
so for the record I'm using a 42
millimeter Apple watch with a classic
leather band which does mean the watch
you're seeing in this video cost $700
that's as much as an iPhone so for 700
bucks you do need to stand out from the
crowd and be noticeably better than the
rest of the smart watches out there but
does it do that okay well first of all
there are a bunch of different band
options since the band on the Apple
watch one of its best features is that
it's easily interchangeable and you can
buy any of Apple's pretty expensive
bands or there are some third party
bands that are starting to pop up to but
smartwatches in general are supposed to
show you notifications from your phone
means you have to take your phone out
your pocket less and then anything extra
is a bonus so here's how the Apple watch
works you have the touchscreen on the
front and then two physical buttons on
the side one is a knob called digital
crown that also presses in as a button
and then the other one is a much more
tactile button but the digital crown is
a bit softer kind of requires you to
squeeze the whole watch to press it
neither of them are customizable so you
can't map them to functions you use more
and then on the screen you have your
watch face and if you press the digital
crown button you get brought to all your
watch apps and these I'll get to in a
second from the watch face just like on
the iPhone you swipe down to view all of
your iPhones notifications where you can
clear one at a time
or just clear them all which is actually
really nice and then there's this swipe
up from the bottom into what's called
glances and glances are these little
cards with glanceable information kind
of like Google now cards and they come
from the apps that you have installed on
your watch so they can give you all
kinds of info with a single swipe also
gives you music controls for iTunes or
Spotify or whatever you use and even the
shortcut to toggle airplane mode or pin
your iPhone to find it if you've lost it
alright so your apps where do they come
from so the apps on your watch are not
standalone apps they're basically apps
on your iPhone with a watch counterpart
so you have to start to see these apps
in the App Store that say they have an
Apple watch app and that's how you'll
know you're getting into one and you'll
have to activate it on your iPhone to
get it to appear on the watch and if it
has a glances card you can activate that
too and basically all of your
organization is done from the Apple
watch app on the iPhone so organization
of that weird bubbly cluster of icons on
the watch is done from your phone and
the changes are updated pretty much
immediately not sure if this is the best
looking interface for launching apps but
hey it works now actually using the
Apple watch apps is okay
the experience you get really depends on
the functionality built into the watch
app but for the most part they work kind
of well they're just slow if you're
going to open up an app on your watch to
do something you're probably doing it
because it's faster than pulling out
your phone but in a lot of cases Apple
watch apps are so slow that you might as
well just take out your phone and do the
same action at the same speed on a
bigger screen there are some good Apple
watch apps a lot of the built-in ones
are actually the best and they also tend
to make more use of the digital crown
but for the most part I would describe
the app experience as smooth but not
fast you really have to want to use the
watch to use those apps but it's really
best at is notifications so the Apple
watch is really good at just quietly
tapping me on the wrist and alerting me
of a new notification on my iPhone
without me having to take my phone out
of my pocket that's really nice I end up
using my phone less I save a little bit
of battery and a little bit of time by
dismissing stuff I don't want to respond
to without ever touching my phone and
that's what smartwatches should be good
at the haptic engine in the watch the
vibration motor is actually really good
too it's much cleaner and better feeling
it's almost like a tap
on the wrists much better feeling than
any other SmartWatch I've used and it
uses that subtle tap vibration for not
only notifications but reminders and
stuff so like the activity tracker which
reminds me to stand up every once in a
while to reach the fitness goals that
was cool unless it was telling me to
stand up in class and also it's used for
force touch so the Apple watch's display
is pressure-sensitive and as the name
implies you can touch with a little
extra force to open some more options
like clearing all notifications or
changing watch faces and speaking of
watch faces here's a real bummer no
third party watch faces at all no
downloading any other cool watch faces
from the app store and that sucks I mean
that's like half the fun of the Android
wear smartwatches out there but hey
there's your classic Apple lockdown
mentality maybe Apple watch version 2
will get third party watch faces but for
now if you like one of the default ones
and you pick that or you just grab the
one you dislike the least my favorite is
the modular one it kind of sets up like
a regular watch where you use a digital
crown like a dial on the side to get the
information exactly where you want it
and then it constantly gives you that
info it's pretty clean not bad but I
would have loved to have way more watch
face options in the app store seriously
so with all this if you're like me
you're still having a hard time
justifying the price of this iPhone
accessory so let me tell you some other
things it does really well first of all
it has a great display it's an LCD
display at 290 pixels per inch so it's
really bright and really sharp and yet
the blacks get surprisingly black so
even though it's not an oled display
it's awesome both indoors and outdoors
and the watch itself is pretty
comfortable actually very comfortable
even though it's kind of thick it's one
of the most comfortable smartwatches
I've worn which is like a decent amount
it's also got average battery life I'd
say pretty good it's almost always
around a day and a half so it's never
lasted a full two days comfortably but
it's never dead after one day and it has
the best gyroscope I've used in any
SmartWatch it's hands-down the best at
knowing when I'm looking at it and
turning on and then knowing when I'm not
looking at it and turning the screen off
so even if you don't use all the
features like taking phone calls with
the speakerphone or messaging with the
weird gloved emojis or sending
heartbeats even if you never use any of
that it's still pretty good at
patience which is sort of the core of
what it's supposed to do but in terms of
whether or not you should buy one well
just like a battery case for your iPhone
or a camera lens it's an accessory for
your iPhone and it should be treated as
exactly that at the end of the day the
base price it doesn't really stick out
from any other smartwatches in any crazy
way we might just have to wait till
version 2 for that thanks for watching
now talk to you guys in the next one
peace